quand vous avez
une longévité qui accroît une natalité
qui baisse y arrive à un moment vous
pouvez taxer tout ce que vous voulez
c'est essayer de combler un puissant
faux c'est la raison pour laquelle il
faut prendre des mesures paramétriques
et troisièmement vous avez dit que le
débat était tronqué contre contenu dans
de nombreuxeurs limitées plus de 100
heures mes chers collègues trois fois un
PLFSS a été rappelé par Catherine
Desroches alors c'est pas assez pour
discuter de 4800 amendements et si vous
voulez qu'on discute effectivement
jusqu'au bout n'hésitez pas à retirer
ceux qui sont redondants merci donc avis
défavorable de la commission
la vie
[Musique]